can you talk about the album because i
know a lot is it's pretty much done
right but the album called pray for me
pray for me pray for me
that's all i could talk about
in the first single to scare money
that's the first record you know what
i'm saying and um it's coming soon
why that title
um
that title that's what the music um
like
when i came with that title
um
for me i was like halfway
like there with the album and i had like
a handful of records and i was just
sitting on the records and i'm like
i'm like i'm like bro like
if i wasn't trying to force nothing and
trying to come create some [ __ ] to
create some [ __ ] and try to make try to
turn it into like
like bring it to life i'm like no i need
to go listen to these mute like to the
music and let the music
like create the title you feel me so i'm
listening to the music
and then i'm like bro
it sound like like like like like pray
for me like
i need help like you know i'm saying my
life is crazy life is crazy everybody
likes past two years you know what i'm
saying
everybody been going through crazy [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying so
and bro this was like in like
july august
august september when i came with this
title
and [ __ ]
and um
yeah it just seemed like bro [ __ ] just
it's just crazy
and [ __ ] so uh
yeah that's the title of the album bro